i don't have any help today with my
daughter she's actually here
on set running around somewhere at kylie
cosmetics headquarters
every day is take your daughter to work
day i feel like i'm getting into so many
cool beauty things i'm excited about it
kylie jenner's three-year-old daughter
stormy webster
steals the show again in part three of
the beauty mogul's youtube series
taking fans inside her billion dollar
empire
the 23 year old entrepreneur poses for
the camera
as her little girl plays around the
office and when kylie checks the status
of a pic she posted of stormy to
instagram the proud mama makes it clear
who the real star
is 11.8 do you realize how insane it is
i know it's crazy people love stormy
though she's a star
she's the real star
of course kylie brought cameras into her
offices to celebrate the company's
relaunch
as a clean and vegan brand quiet on the
set
shut up just kidding
the three-part series includes multiple
sit-down interviews with kylie
her mom chris and the kylie cosmetics
team
all of whom totally adore little stormy
i think that there's
you know one day we'll all be working
for stormy too probably so
and they might not be that far off
because in part two of the series we
learned
stormy already has her own office
kylie goes to work with stormy and
stormy loves it she just you know
absorbs it this is where you get to hang
out when you come to work
but the cutest moment came courtesy of
stormy's
love for candy
oh okay get out of here
get out of here as for kylie
she's just trying to emulate her own
business savvy mama
what would you say your job title is
business woman
mini mogul yes mini chris jenna being a
mom has become
second nature to me this morning had to
get up at 7 00 am make her breakfast get
her ready
meanwhile i'm in my pajamas and slippers
and i'm like
doing her hair she looks perfect i think
it was just a no-brainer for me and my
mom
and our team to just be surrounded by
strong woman
i hope stormy looks at me the way that i
look at my mom
say hi mommy hi daddy and the love
is mutual back in 2018 shortly after
kylie was named the youngest self-made
billionaire by forbes
chris opened up to e.t about how proud
she is of her youngest kids
rise in the business world miss kylie's
going to be here and about to be a
billionaire
is that insane how proud are you she
works really hard
she made her own money for over a decade
she put it in the bank she saved every
nickel and then when she decided she
really
you know decided on what she wanted to
do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north
and it did really well i'm proud of all
my kids because
they really have an amazing work ethic
and they roll their sleeves up
and really do what they love to do so
that makes me really happy like with
kendall and her modeling she just knew
what she wanted to do
same with kylie and her makeup they all
find their passion
and when that happens it's like it's
[Music]
magical